so by now you've probably seen the  harrowing footage of dante wright being  shot in what was supposed to be a  routine traffic stop and reports are  that one of the officers on the scene  intended to draw a taser but instead  drew her service weapon and shot dante  wright in the chest  now many people have suggested that this  officer could be charged with  involuntary manslaughter and that could  fit but this has happened before in new  hope pennsylvania  an officer shot an unarmed man in a  holding cell thinking that he was  pulling his taser the man survived and  the district attorney didn't press any  charges though in two other cases in  oakland california and tulsa oklahoma  where the police officers drew a gun  instead of a taser they were convicted  of killing the victims in those cases  so we'll see what happens in this  particular case it's a tragedy either  way